>> So good evening or
good afternoon. For those of
you who don't know
me, I'm Nicholas Negroponte.
I'm one of the co-founders
of the Media Lab.
And I'm not really going
to be the emcee But you'll
see me come and go.
And if people take too
long, I might be pushed out
to grab them off the
stage. I was not only a
colleague of Muriel's. I think it's
fair to say she was
my best friend. I've known
her since the early 1960s
and she had an
enormous influence on me.
And even though she
was roughly 20 years
older than I, we
did things almost like brother
and sister. We traveled
together. We worked together.
I was in the
architecture department at one
end of the building
on Massachusetts Avenue and she
was on the other
end. And we really spent
so much time together, I
would say on average
dinner twice a week.
That's average. And partly
that was because her
house and MIT, if you drew
a straight line, I was in
the middle of it. So she
would pick me up
with this Chevrolet Impala that
was infested with dog hair.
(Chuckles).
>> I would get into
garbage bags because I wore a
suit and a tie in those
days. And I
would get into the car
with my garbage bags.
We would come -- she
would drop me off at Building
7. And she would go
to the MIT Press. And
then when the Media Lab
got created on the Visible
Language Workshop, which you'll
hear a lot about,
became very much part
of the initial groups that
sort of formed the Media
Lab And Muriel worked
here as one of
our most colorful and
important faculty members. Now,
there are two Muriels. There's
a Muriel that we know
from her work. And
there are quite a few
people in the room who didn't
know her as a person.
A, because you may be
too young. Or you just
didn't have the chance to
know Muriel. And the Muriel
that we see in her
work is crisp. It's incisive.
It's almost cartesian. It's
maybe even Helvetica if you
could use the word
generally to describe something
rather Swiss and precise.
And the Muriel --
the second Muriel, the
persona, I guess the first
word would be much
more colorful. Less decisive.
For those of you
who remember going out
for dinner with Muriel and
how she ordered food at
a restaurant, it drove
waiters crazy. She would say,
well, no, I'll have --
well, can you make this
without -- actually I would
prefer that if it doesn't
-- the succotash without
the corn. And it was --
it was a much -- it
wasn't crisp. And so the two
Muriels created an influence
that just never left
this laboratory. And I'm
sure many people who didn't
know the persona will by
the end of today.
Because a lot of the
speakers knew Muriel very well.
A lot of the
participants also did. So
the coffee break, everybody
will have Muriel
Cooper stories. And I'm not
going to bore you with
too many of these. But
in the early days of
the Media Lab, we had a
lot of funding from the
military. And there was a
General who was in what
I think was then called
the Seventh Army, which was
all of the Army in
Europe, who came to the
Media Lab and met Muriel.
And when he meets Muriel,
he says, how much
do you know about theaters? And
she said, I know a lot.
I studied to be an
actress. And he said, it's not
that kind of theater. And he
then sort of -- he
says to -- these
guys don't come alone. There
are privates. There are
people. He said, where is
the men's room? And he
said, a hand grenade's
throw down the corridor,
sir. Muriel used that expression
for the next 10
years. She would tell people,
oh, you need the men's
room? It's a hand
grenade's throw down the
corridor. (Chuckles) So that's
the kind of person
Muriel was. When Jerry
Wiesner and I were raising
money, this was before
either building was built,
he brought Avery Fischer
around And he said,
let's go introduce Avery
Fischer. And he introduces
Muriel. He says, Muriel,
this is Avery Fischer. And
Muriel says, oh, are you
the fat cat? And Jerry
wanted to die. He never
for gave her. He quoted
the story over and over
again. But he always did it
with a lot of laughs. So
I think today you'll hear --
if you don't hear explicit
stories, you're going to hear
about a person who
really made the Media
Lab different. We pride
ourself on being different.
But boy, Muriel was very,
very different. So in keeping
with that, when we
did this event, or when
we were starting to think
of this event, it's almost
the case that the people
who aren't here are dead.
That was the only
excuse. Almost everybody else
came. And the --
really. It's almost 100%
showing in terms of the
-- who was invited and
who actually got here. And
then when we asked people
to help with the graphics
and people to help
do the event, we go
to our usual port of call,
the gold standard of graphics,
we went to Pentagram.
Now, we go to Pentagram
for everything. So going
to Pentagram wasn't that
special. But Pentagram, thanks
to Aron -- thanks
to Aron Vinegar, Aron FAy, Michael
Bierut and I don't know if
I know -- if I
met Daisy
Lee. Are
you here?
>> (Inaudible).
>> She does all of
the work. She's not even here.
But you guys, you know,
you hit it out of the
box. And I know exactly why.
And we're going to see
this again over the afternoon.
So I don't have to
introduce the next speaker.
Muriel will. In a video
that I believe we'll roll
in a second. Thank you.
(Applause).
>> Muriel was with MIT
Press for quite a while. She's
been with the Media Lab
for quite a bit.
She's always been two
or three steps ahead
of me
with everything she did.
And it's an honor
and a pleasure
to have Muriel join
us today thanking you.
(Applause).
>> I have a
confession. And I hope that
everybody in the audience
will forgive me. In
those early days when
we were both very
young and terrified, I made
the mistake -- I remember
how I did it. I
remember when I did it.
And I think I remember where
I did it. But I'm
damned if I know
why I did it. I
introduced Nicky to Ricky.
(Chuckles)
(Applause)
>> Can you -- I know you're
filming this or doing something.
But turn the lights
down so I can
see the audience, please, please
just turn them down.
Somebody has a switch for
the lights and I know you
don't want to do it.
But it will be fine.
Just turn them down, please,
so I can see
the audience. Those lights that
are in my face. That's
just better. Oh, yes. I
have to do that every
time you give a speech.
You can't see the audience
And if you can't see
a face, how can you give
a chat? Well, my opening
lines were not Nicky to Ricky.
But I was going to say
that Nicholas -- I was
introduced to Nicholas by
Muriel. She changed my
life. Lives have
moments. Lives are not
continuums. You might look
back and think they
are continuums. But no, they
are just moments. And forget
a lot of the shit
between the moments. But
the moments, they really
change you. And it's
not that you should forget
the stuff between it. But
it's really just stuff. A
lot of stuff. Like
George Carlin used to talk
about stuff. Anyway, she
introduced me to Nicholas
when he had the
Architecture Machine And
that was a change in my life. And
her wanting to introduce me to
somebody else who she felt
was very important was a
change in my life.
Recently people have
been telling me that
I'm abrasively charming.
(Chuckles).
>> And there's a certain
truth in both of those
things that I am abrasive
and I am
charming. I know you're not
supposed to say either
about yourself. But it's
perfectly clear what I'm saying.
And if you're clear,
that beats every other thing.
Just being clear is enough.
And so I could
never get any -- I
wouldn't have gotten the media
-- the MIT Press or
anybody else to publish any
of my little books. And
I had been doing
books for a while. I just
have an idea and I do a
little book And I don't have
a publisher. I spit it
out But she indulged me
and got them to do
exceptions about a whole bunch
of little booklets that I
did over the years.
And they really -- they
really -- she really changed
my life. I did something
for her. But I didn't know
I was doing it. And she
didn't know I was doing it.
But in the last year of
her life, I finally got to
her -- and she's everything that
Nicholas said. The dogs,
the car. Her taking off
her shoes, walking around
in her socks. I mean, it's
just -- but she didn't know
she was doing it. It was
just what she was. If I
-- I used to dress funny when
I went to Penn but I
knew purposely I was
trying to get attention. She
wasn't trying to get
attention. She was just
being herself. Just about as
genuine as she could
be. That was just
her. I was always more
phony than she was.
(Chuckles).
>> I came
and saw her stuff here
a number of times.
By the way, this is
-- I said it to Juan
Enriquez as I came in.
We had a quick
conversation. And I had
never said that before.
But I realized
that it's something
I should repeat
This is the greatest
real school in the
world. There's some woowoo
schools that are probably
nice where little kids count
beads and they do
things and they think they
learn to be nice people
and all of those things.
There's a lot of
little woowoo schools with
different things and
experimental schools. But
this school is extraordinary.
We, what Nicholas
has done, others following
Nicholas, paralleling Nicholas, the
effect he has
had. I walked around. I
was early because I had
nothing to do. And I
walked around the school.
And my goodness. It
really is Disneyland for
grownups. It's a dream. It's
the waking dream. And so
this is a great place
that we're all sitting
in here. And great places
attract great people. And
Muriel was a great person.
She was just simply a
great person. And I
finally convinced her -- I
started a conference I ran
for a while called TED.
And I finally convinced her
to come to one of
the fifth TED Conferences.
And she came with David
Small, who is in the
audience here. They came
and I had her scheduled
I think for the second
day. I don't remember when
you were scheduled David. I
think it was the second
day. It might have
been the first. And she
came with David. And they
had nothing. They had
nothing to show. They hadn't
worked on anything. They just
came in. And I
was just depressed about that.
And so I changed the --
I could do what I
wanted. I changed the program.
And I think they were
on the fourth day.
And then they stayed
up for three days.
And they developed their
presentation. It was a
charrette. Beyond charrettes. It
was amazing. I told
David if I say
something that at least makes
the story understandable not
to stand up. If I
say something that really disturbs
him and is not factual
that he should stand up
and stop me. I'm just telling
you my memory of it.
And then they did
this amazing presentation. And it
was live. They had
computers all over. This is
a long time ago. This
is just a long time --
it's when nothing worked
(Chuckles).
>> I mean literally
nothing worked. You knew
that anybody who was doing
a presentation with
a computer it wasn't
going to work.
They would have to boot
it up again. It was
just the way it was.
It was acceptable.
And it was astonishing.
It was just astonishing.
And it was my dream.
It was a dream. And
I always stayed on
stage. I think I left the
stage to watch it that time.
I always used to stay on
stage so I could stay
behind people to have them
stop talking. And I left
the stage and watched it.
And I was transplanted. I
didn't think you could
do that. And I
said, it was like flying
through information. Flying through
understanding. It was something
new. We have gotten so
used to it. We
see it in all of
the Goddamn ads now. We're
always flying through letters
and flying through things.
But that was Muriel and
her students. It was
something that was broke
through -- it was
a break-through in thinking
about computer graphics
and content. Not computer
graphics and just
graphics and pretty. And
flexing muscles. It was
with content. Content and
time. And it was three
dimensional maps of time. It
was all kind of aerial
maps. It was the Cirque
du Soleil with people with
printouts on them. It
was special. It was really
special. I recorded -- I didn't
record it. I can't even
type. But I had people
record things. And that little
video is, as far as I
know, the only evidence that
she and David and her
students and her head
and her time and her
dog and her car and the
-- you know and everything,
put that together. And it's
become an icon of a
moment in history when
some things came together.
It's like the photograph
that Watson and Crick
used to build their
Tinkertoy model. It's a moment
in time that put
something together that we
can stamp when people
started thinking that
way. And it allowed
people to think differently.
Because the tool allows you
to think of things you
couldn't think of, except for
the first person who
does that. Michelangelo stands in
front of a huge piece
of stone. And he
wouldn't be able to
do anything about it until
somebody had invented, prior
to that, a hammer and a
chisel. And then they say, oh,
I can let Moses out
because he has a hammer
and chisel. But he couldn't
even think of doing
that without -- he couldn't
scrape him out with his
fingernails. So her tools
were these abilities to
think of things that
have changed our lives.
Something came up maybe
before this. And I
forget the conversation. I
forget who it was. But
what came up is something
I was thinking about a
few weeks ago of how
my life changed. A certain
time when I was at
Penn. I'm 82. So I
can know how many years ago
that was. And I was
doing the student magazine
then. There wasn't such
a thing as offset
printing except by
an experimental printer in
downtown Philadelphia, Gene
Philbin at Falcon Press.
But before everything was
-- before that everything
was done with the way
you set type and doing
that. So you couldn't even
think of actually doing
something else You couldn't think
of doing the thing
that Pentagram does. They
wouldn't come into your
head because you --
they couldn't be actualized. So
that -- they aren't the
creation. But the tool
allows you to think of
things. And her -- she
skipped the idea that without th
e tool, she broke
through and asked of
our new inventions, do
something that she was
-- it was her waking
dream. And we benefited
from that. Well, I won't
beat that dead horse There's
a little light there. And
I'm -- I don't know how
much time I spoke I know
I have 15 minutes. And
this takes 6 minutes. And
I realize I can't write better
than I wrote then. It's
just 6 minutes. And this
was the -- I did
a book called "Information
Architects." And I dedicated
it to Muriel many, many,
many years ago. And
this is what I read. I
put that in the book. And this
is what I read at the
services for her after she
died. And I was with her
the day before she died,
a day and a half
before she died. She was at
an AGI Conference over in
Cambridge. And we were
hanging with Bobbi Greenberg. She
and I and a
few others. And she
had to get back home.
Nicholas' memory is slightly
different than mine. I
don't know what's right.
It doesn't make any
difference what's right. She came
home and Nicholas asked her to
introduce somebody and we know that
she passed away suddenly at that
moment. But she showed twice
the thing that you have
all seen I think or
it's around this show or
they will show it today.
I don't know what the
program is today. But it was
shown -- we saw it live
at TED. It was shown
one other time afterwards.
And then the last time
was at the AGI
Conference in Cambridge. And
it was remarkable. So
I'm going to come
down here and read that.
I do have 6 minutes,
whoever is keeping time?
Do I still have 6
minutes left? Say yes, please.
Well, I'm coming here
because I saw there
was more light here. Somebody
turned down those lights.
(Chuckles)
>> Okay I'm not
good at reading. I'm sorry.
I'm better at talking.
But this is good to
read. I believe that Muriel has
wings. We met. I was 29
and she was 38.
We last laughed and planned
together on the day
before she was to die I
was 59 and she was 68. I
knew her for 30 years. On
my first meeting, I felt
those wings as they wrapped
around me like a
mother hen. I was
sharp tongued, arrogant, coming to
the MIT Press trying
to get my ideas published.
And she walked me through
the door after door
that I couldn't myself navigate
or open. I next saw
the wings as they
created a wind and showed
me the wind of change.
She introduced me to
Nicholas. And the
notion of dreams. Finding
your way through
information. A different kind
of navigation. The next winds
-- wings I saw
her wear where the
wings of a peace dove
as she red-eyed and
passionate, struggled to
get McCullin's book "Is
Anyone Taking Any
Notice?" published. That poignant
book about the Vietnam
War and death.
She wore wings on
her many cardiographic exercises.
Flying on airplane
wings, flying in space
over maps, over information.
Watching as the aerial
perspective changed with
clouds refocusing her vision
of a man-created
reality. The wings of
triumph and the aura of
discovery were all around
Muriel at the TED5
conference She worked with David
Small for three days
to assemble together the
premiere of a presentation,
which she hesitantly
at first, then with
noticeable joy, showed to
the extraordinary audience of
that conference. It changed
forever the visual paradigm
of information for
all who saw the presentation.
As I came on stage
holding back the tears
of join that come
when you have seen
something absolutely magnificent, I
said, Muriel, I believe we
have all had dreams of
flying. And here you
allowed us to make
those dreams a reality as
we are flying through
information. It was a
real-time display of heavenly
navigation. Later here at
the Media Lab, she
once again went through the
presentation with Bill Mitchell
and myself as bookends.
And the three of
us talking to Nicholas' class.
And then three
months later, having retitled
the presentation Flying
Through Information, she
showed the videotape to
the Alliance Graphique
Internationale, AGI, at
Cambridge, England. Henry Steiner,
who is from
Hong Kong and then
President AGI, had seen it
at TED. Bobbi Greenberg
and I spoke with her
of what was going to
happen next and what the
dreams of flying through information
released in each of us.
For me it was
the ability to control
one's personal understanding. That
was the day
before she died. I do
believe Muriel has wings. They
are wings that will
encourage her students to
be more of themselves.
They will allow the
people seeing her
epiphanic and information structure
to dream of
understanding She was an
architect of information. She
now has the
wings that few get in
death. She will be in
the waking dreams of those
who are touched by
the wind from her feathers
of change and discovery.
(Applause).
[Music].
>> Can you see
me? Hello. Hello. There are
two very important things that
the Visible Language Workshop
is looking at. One is
the way in which graphics,
which we define in
the broadest sense, can
be used to filter,
define, qualify and
edit that information. And
secondly, what --
the interface or the relationship
-- the surface or the
access of the person
to the machine can be
liked to promote the most
creative and the most
generative means of communication.
And again if you
look at the
computer as an environment
in which you do multiple
tasks, and which is
ubiquitous in your life,
then it's even more
important that this
personalization and configurability
take place. Because today
I may want
to work on
music and then go
to my cookbook.
>> Right.
>> And then
read my newspaper. Or
design my newspaper.
>> Right.
[Music].
>> Don't go
away. Where are my notes?
On the back of this.
Now I've lost my fucking notes.
Huh? (Chuckles) >> No. So -- oh,
Jesus, here it is. Don't stop.
Here we
go. I'm
ready.
[Music]
(Applause).
>> Hi I'm
Michael Bierut of Pentagram.
We have assembled a
panel to talk
about Muriel as a
designer. Like some of
the other unlucky
people here, I don't
think I ever met Muriel.
I sent her a
letter in the late '70s
that Rob Wiesenberger found
and sent me a copy of
that seems to indicate that I
may have met her. I
can't really -- I don't
remember writing the letter and
I don't remember what
provoked me to write this
letter. But I corresponded with
her in some way.
So at least we
have that remote connection. But
her influence, as Nicholas
said, is so broad
and so deep, that
almost anyone practicing graphic
design today would say
that they have somehow
met Muriel Cooper.
We've got three people
who can talk about this
in more depth. Aron
Vinegar, who is a professor
at the University of Oslo
and the author of
several books, including "I
Am a Monument," which is
about Muriel and her
work on "Learning from
Las Vegas," the epical
volume by Denise Scott
Brown and Robert Venturi.
Ben Fry, the creator
of the programing
environment
called
--
(Chuckles).
>> Processing.
>> -- Called Processing I'm
sorry; you need a better,
catchier name than that.
>> Basic, something basic.
(Chuckles).
>> He's a
winner of the National Design
Award from the Cooper-Hewitt Museum
for Interactive
Design, as is at
least one other speaker
here this evening.
And finally, Ellen Lupton,
the senior curator for
design at the National
Design Museum. And she's the
person who sort of
hands out those awards. And
I will point out this
very evening is the
evening of the National
Design Awards in New York
City. Ellen is honor
bound to be there but instead here.
(Chuckles).
>> So that just
shows where the priorities
are when Muriel Cooper
has something to
say about them. So I
would like to invite Ellen
to talk
about her and
her legacy.
>> That's great. I
did get to meet
Muriel. Very profound.
And I was in
the audience when Ricky
didn't take his shoes off
but she did and
showed that amazing video. And
I was trying to think,
what would she have
made of this today?
All of you here,
a giant book
about her work. An
honorary elevator button
(Chuckles).
>> Her name
type set in 35,000
point purple Helvetica.
I think she would have liked it.
(Chuckles)
>> You know,
girls are supposed to be
embarrassed by all of
the attention. But I'll
tell you a secret,
we like it. It's good. It's good.
(Chuckles).
>> And what would
she have thought about the
world of media today,
this exploding,
uncontrolled metastatic networked
mass of
digital communication? She said
it all. She really
knew what was happening.
And it's been
a great pleasure to think
again about her work.
And to read
the wonderful essays about
her voice and
her students in the
book that Rob and David
put together. Muriel can't
be here today. But I
want her to be here. And
so I pulled together some
of her words. Because
she needs to speak. And
she was so articulate
about the questions that
obsess people like me and
Michael. What is a
book? What is an author?
What is the role of
graphic designers in all of
that? What is the nature
of communication? And what is
it that we do,
damn it, that adds value
to communication? I pulled out
a couple of her
most stunning and important
or famous books. But
they are the books
in which she had the
most role as an author. And
in her decades at MIT
and her role at
MIT Press, she was creating
systems and ways that
books could kind of
generate themselves. But she
also really got her
fingers and hands and
mind into certain books that
very much bear her
stamp as a co-author
of information. She thought
that books were like
movies. She wanted to
eliminate the gap between
the designer and the
process of printing and
shaping information. So she
played with offset
as this kind of live
medium, emotion medium. She used
the grid in her
amazing Bauhaus book as
a way to give
structure and architecture. But
also to create constant
change and surprise. My
favorite part is the
index. I'm sure she spent a
lot of time on that index.
And I think this is --
this is actually the
manuscript for the Bauhaus book.
This is what we
do. We take a pile
of shit like that. These
thousands of pages. That is
not a book. It is
not a book until someone
comes through and gives it
shape and makes it accessible
to human beings to find
their way in and
out. And she talked
about that. She talked about
graphic design as a
kind of filtering of
this mass, this stream of
information, the junk that
authors hand us. And
that we make into
something coherent And she
saw that the future
would give readers and writers
better ways to find
their way through information,
to give it a better
shape. And she was
interested in information that
should go away. She
didn't feel that
everything should stay on
the planet forever. And
she thought that
designers had a role
in making data disappear. I
wish more people had
paid attention to that.
I think that's really important.
And in this book,
which Aron will talk about
more, we can kind of
see the battle for
authorship between two
great women of design
theory and thinking.
Muriel Cooper and Denise
Scott Brown, the real
author and the graphic
design author. And Muriel
I think was frustrated by
being told what to
do by the author.
And she created this incredible
book that provided a
kind of new interface
for connecting image and text,
for allowing us to
absorb the image as a
kind of text. And to
kind of fit those things
together in an incredibly eloquent
way So if you come
in close to this
book, you'll see that
that wide letting made space
for these little figure
numbers which are keyed
to the pictures. And it
allowed the reader to
go back and forth
between the text and the
image in an absolutely
brilliant way. Apparently Denise
Scott Brown didn't like
that very much.
And there exists in
the papers of Muriel
Cooper interchanges between
these two great women
fighting about the book.
And Denise thought it
was too interesting, too
Bauhaus, too much noise
of the graphic
designer in there.
And what she wanted
was something more
conventional. Which is what
she got later. Right? I'll
let Muriel have the
last word on that. Talking
about the author. And you
can see here the
kind of frustration of
graphic designers feeling boxed
in and told what
to do. And what she
really wanted is for us to
all have tools to be
authors and designers and
publishers. And boy, did we
get those tools. Okay?
>> Yeah.
>> Thank you.
>> Aron?
(Applause).
>> Thank you
very much. I came to
Muriel Cooper's work directly
through her design work.
I never met her
in person. I first encountered
her actually when
I started working on
"Learning from Las Vegas."
Like many people,
I first encountered the
book on the right,
which is the
revised version, the boring
version I guess,
that was designed
by Denise Scott Brown
And then worked myself
back to
the original version designed
by Muriel Cooper.
And I guess I
was kind of stunned by
her approach to design
and vision, which I
initially, you know, was
directed towards the design
work. This kind of
complicated I think prefiguring
her later interests in
the Visible Language
Workshop on texture,
layering, transparency, a
kind of dynamism to
the text, interrelations between
text and image. As
Ellen said, you can
see the extreme letting, the
triple spacing of the
main text juxtaposed by the
very tight text in the
margins and so forth
Here is another example
of the layout of
Muriel Cooper's design. And
then you can see
the difference that Denise Scott
Brown really did not
like the Swiss treatment
of her book. And really
wanted a much more
boring or she called
it deadpan approach to
the book with very
regularized text and image.
The kind of --
the images grouped together
here. Here you can see
the use of the grid. This
was drawn for me by
Sally Steiner in showing
you the grid that Muriel
Cooper used. And then
again, this image, which
was also supposed to
kind of replicate the
movement through the city and
the lines of the text
are kind of the
roadways or the highways.
And the numbering of
the images are meant
to be like signs. So
your way of reading is
like moving through the city.
And this kind of
sense of movement is also
kind of demonstrated in
these layouts. This is a
layout for Part 1 of
"Learning from Las Vegas."
So Muriel Cooper could
see the arrangements of
text and image and
flow and so forth.
And the filmic dimension is
really important here. But
I think I want to
mention what I learned from her,
what I think about her
work that's important. And
this is the kind
of triadic relationship
between communication, movement
and experience. And I
think I have
a little bit of
a different attitude to what
communication is perhaps than
traditional designers. I'm not
a designer. And to
me communication is
exposing us to
the risk of experience.
That means traversing
something, pushing against
limits, undergoing something.
And this
kind of attitude towards
experience really is about
discovering a path.
It's not formulating a
method. It is not
deploying kind of preconceived
formats, whether those are grids
or not. It is really
the exposure for us
to experience something new.
And to undergo it.
Not to have an
experience. But to -- and
not to own it or
anything like that. But to
actually undergo it and
move along a path. So
a hodos (phonetic), a
path. Method -- the
word method consists of the
word hodos, which is
path And I
don't think she ever
deployed anything preconceived
Although of course she
was deploying Swiss kind
of graphic design.
But the kind of material
kind of spills out over
there. And I think what
she brought to her
further work, Visible Language
Workshop, is that the
book was really undergoing
a rapid change in
1972. Things were
opening up. And this was
a site of experiment. The
book was no longer
an archaic stillness. But
was opening up and kind
of proliferating by the
work of people like,
you know, designers at the
time and theorists and
so forth. And Muriel Cooper
was at the forefront of
that. And that kind
of issue about movement
and information and complexity,
a book isn't
just to be read
for information. But something like
the size of the
"Learning from Las Vegas"
book, the original version,
you can't sit there
and read it. You need to
place it on a table You
need to move it around.
Explore it. Move through
the information. And this
kind of attitude gets
carried on and carried
forth in her later work
with the Visible Language
Workshop But a lot
of that was enabled by
her exploration of book
design I think. So that's
what I was impressed with
with her work and
my encounter
with her
work.
>> Thanks, Aron. Ben?
(Applause).
>> So I
don't typically read when
doing a talk.
I've been ill lately
and have a four-month-old
at home so
I have the memory of
a mosquito. And I want
to make sure that
I give this subject its
due here. So at the
risk of dating myself,
I think I probably saw the
work of Muriel and the VLW
first in a Wired magazine.
A couple of years
later, I was a
senior at Carnegie-Mellon
and recently VLW
alum. Suguru Ishizaki
brought David Small
and John Maeda to speak.
And this was the first
time that I saw
how my interest
in graphic design and
Computer Science might
actually be combined in
a more interesting way
than sort of jamming
them together. As a
student I had already
worked professionally as a
graphic designer and
separately as a software
developer. But always
kind of hated computer
graphics. Because I found
them to represent
everything I despised about
the usual collision of
art and engineering.
A bunch of engineers
trying to replicate a
Mondriaan painting and
calling it art or
3D graphics with spears
and cubes and incandescent
RGB colors So synthetic
and alien that they hardly
seem at home with
the computer itself. I
loved how Muriel remained a
designer first. And it
shows the influence of
her work as seen
in students. Often when
designers start working
with computation as a
medium, there's a
tendency to shut off
their design intention because
they are in this f
oreign and sort of
technical space. To make
the transition, you really
need to think --
keep your critical eye and
treat computation as just
another medium that is
as imperfect as any other.
And learn from its
working within its constraints
by also trying to
challenge yourself to
overcome them. Muriel did
this with her students
with the VLW in
exploring things like depth
of field and blur in
text. Many years before
these would become
commonplace. These came
from an approach
grounded in fields like
photography and film and
typography and a
desire to make this cold
medium a little bit more
humanistic In 2001 I
had been a student
of John Maeda for three
years and began working
with Casey Reas on
what would become Processing.
A project that
seeks to make it
easier to merge these disciplines
of design and code.
And it is a direct
descendant of coding libraries that
date to the VLW.
Plus the pedagogical side of
what we did at the
ACG. And finally, the
desire to sketch with
code. So writing short
programs that are easily
iterated upon, the same
way that you work in
your sketch book. The
VLW name even lives
on as the font format
used by Processing, which
stores information in exactly
the same way as the
type used in that
information landscape studio we
saw earlier. Millions of
users later, we
have a Mission
Statement for the Processing
project which reads,
Processing seeks to ruin
the careers of talented
designers by tempting
them away from their
usual tools and into the
world of program and
computation. Similarly, the
project is designed to
turn engineers and
computer scientists to
less gainful employment
as artists and designers.
(Chuckles).
>> And I
hope that point would resonate
with Muriel. After she took
a class with
Nicholas Negroponte, she's quoted
to have said the
code on
screen didn't make
any Goddamn sense.
(Chuckles).
>> I've always felt that these
are precisely the people that I
want to bring into the field.
The technically inclined
will always find
their way regardless.
But they will
also make things that
are more suited to their
technical interests. So
a field gets interesting,
however, and only really
truly evolves when it
expands by bringing in
people with different abilities
and kinds of
experiences. And as far
as accessibility, we have
come a long way
since the VLW era where
this work was limited to
research labs using
computers the size of a
mini fridge. By the early
2000s you could buy
a computer for a few
hundred dollars to do this
type of work, which
means that the means was
in place. We just provided
the platform -- or
we just needed to
provide the platform,
which Casey and I
sought to do with Processing.
And now in the
current decade the
means is ubiquitous and
Processing continues with
initiatives like the p5.js
project which takes the same
ideas and tries to
rethink them for
sort of contemporary web
setting. But more
importantly, Lauren McCarthy
has led the project
with renewed focus
on inclusion and diversity.
Meaning that we're at a
point where we have
more room to consider
what this means socially and
how we can really
extend the boundary of
those participating in the
field. The evolution
over the last couple
of decades reminds me
of a wonderful John
Adams quote, the paraphrase
goes something like, I
must study politics
so that sons have
something like liberty to
study mathematics and
philosophy. And my
sons will study geography
and commerce and
agriculture to give their
children the right to
study painting, poetry,
music and architecture. We
owe an enormous debt
to Muriel and her
students for providing this
basis to us and
I'm honored to be
participating today Thank you.
(Applause).
>> When Ellen
and then Aron were
talking about the tension
that occurred
between Muriel Cooper
and Denise Scott Brown
and the
design and production of
"Learning from Las Vegas,"
one of the things
that actually throws in a
sharp relief is that period
when authors actually
did turn over to
designers a pile of
manuscripts that
looked like that photograph
that Ellen showed.
And then there was
no choice but to have
a designer or some appointed
professional with
Archaean technical skills,
knowing the names
of typefaces, knowing
how to do color
separations and how
to create mechanical
artwork that could communicate
intention to a
printer. All of those things
were like what Abby Miller
calls black arts in
a way. That civilians
didn't know and weren't
meant to know. And
certainly authors weren't meant
to know or even
have an opinion about.
So hence, that collision was
so acute I think. Now
-- and then as Ben
just said, now we're
in a period where indeed
the means of production
are in everyone's hands. And
is it for the better
do you think, Ben?
>> No question. Because
I think the --
again, it's --
it only gets interesting
as you bring the other
kinds of people into it.
So it's kind
of a -- you know,
you have people who come
in who are
beginners, but they are
experts somewhere else.
So I think it's
really fascinating to take somebody
who has that --
something that they are expert
at but they are kind
of bringing that into something new
And that's only
-- you know, so the
idea that the --
where Muriel was bringing
things like from typography,
just obvious things,
for somebody who
has worked with
film or photography,
that motion blur and
depth of field are just,
you know, the norm.
But for somebody
who is thinking about
things from an engineering
perspective, well, I'm
trying to get the shapes
on screen And it's like,
well -- so
being able to kind of
merge those things together
in a way that it's
just that's what you get
at that sort of intersection
essentially. So I think the
only way you can do
that is get as many
people as possible kind
of using these kinds
of tools and making
messes
with them
first.
>> Aron?
>> Just a clarification, the
-- this is not an
answer to that question.
But a bit of
detail with the "Learning
from Las Vegas"
book, it definitely wasn't
dumping a pile of papers
like these are people
who had very
strong Denise Scott Brown,
Robert Ventura, had very
strong design
ideas and thought of
themselves as designers.
>> Yeah.
>> So it was very
overdeveloped or thought about in
kind of very specific
ways by
the time it
arrived there.
>> That's interesting. And
this takes us down
kind of a dangerously
Archaean
graphic
design road.
>> Love it; love it.
>> I figured that,
Ellen. Good. But I think
that it's easy if you're
a graphic designer to
look at Muriel's design
for that book as being
the designed one.
And to look at the
second -- the revised
edition and the one that
I, in fact, first saw
and only knew for many
years as being sort of
like this undesigned piece of
crap that was like
done -- put together
by untutored people. But when
-- you know, the
intention behind it was very,
very powerful in terms --
and Denise Scott Brown's
objections to Muriel's design
were really articulated and
very -- can you
sort of describe
what Denise wanted out
of that book?
>> I think it's all a
matter of timing.
So actually it's odd
because much is made
of the conflict between
Muriel Cooper and
Denise Scott Brown
as Muriel Cooper said,
it was a battle of
wits, you know. And it was
a really kind of --
a real conflict. But
you know, they had
many things in common.
I could go
through them. It's interest in
movement. They both were
interested in multiple
graphic modes of
representing or
accounting for sensory
plenitude and information
landscapes. I could
go on and on. So why
was the conflict? And of course
a lot of it is
about timing and so forth.
You know, that second book
you could say is
a treatise. It's an idea of
a text. It wants to be
a book. You know, it
wants to get
across a set of
premises or polemics.
>> It's also
more accessible. It's
a little paperback.
>> Inexpensive.
>> In keeping away
from the more pragmatic economics
and things like that.
>> But that's key I think
as a reader. As much as
I love the big book,
I don't want
to actually interact with
it that much.
>> But the other
one was a kind
of sense of the text.
Or what JJ
Gibson would call a sensory
ecology that you don't get
text purified of its
sensory plenitude. And that's what
you get in the
first book is a kind
of sense of the text.
And the second book,
you get the idea of a
text or a treatise or a
polemic. And those are kind
of different desires but
originally Denise Scott Brown
they wanted a
huge book
right at
the beginning.
>> They got it.
(Chuckles).
>> Yeah, belatedly. And
so these kinds of sense
of timings and what
you want to kind
of achieve polemically with your
body of work shifts overtime
>> What's
interesting is the
revised edition, there's nothing
to do
with that book
except read it. Right?
Like looking at it
is no fun. For me
at least. There's some plates
in it that you
can look at. But basically
you have no choice --
if you want to
engage with that book, you
have one way of doing it,
which is reading
it. Whereas I would
maintain in the First
Edition and newly rereleased
is you can really
engage with that book
without actually reading it.
And without actually perceiving
any of the
ideas, in fact. And people
will -- you know, have
done and will do that.
So I sort of get
-- those two ways of
looking at text is really
pronounced. And I think one
of the things that I
wonder is was -- and
Ben, I'll put this to
you. Was she a reader? Was
she frustrated by kind of
the linear nature of
a traditional book? And
that information landscape
>> I didn't
get the opportunity to
work with her
>> But do
you get a sense
from the --
>> I think from the --
I think what's interesting
about the information
landscape and -- Richard
touched on it earlier as
far as this idea of
how you actually move
through a space of information.
And I think it's
kind of -- for people
who like working with information,
that that's kind of --
these are the things that
roll around in their heads
-- our heads --
and keep us up at
night. So I think that
was the kind of thing
that's kind of rolling around for
her. And that this is like
-- this is just the
way it's working in her
head Then she makes a layout
for a book like the
Las Vegas book, that's kind
of a moment frozen in
time of that picture.
It's been in constant motion.
And then all of a
sudden here is this
snapshot that we're putting out
in front of people. So
I think that sort of
thing, you know, is
really what comes through. How
do you capture that
motion and
movement through
the information?
>> I think Nicholas
and Ricky both kind of
referred to the revelatory quality
of that presentation
of information landscapes the
first time at TED5.
And what strikes me
if you sort of see
it today, it's --
there's not a single
kind of, you know,
candy bar commercial on
television that doesn't use
some sort of --
kind of move that kind
of first saw the light
of day in that thing. So
have we reached some sort
of endpoint? Ellen, as
a curative member, have
we reached some
sort of endpoint where
now we await the
next thing, the next kind
of transformation?
Which may be
just emojis or something?
I don't know.
(Chuckles).
>> Well I think
now we're talking about
now having text everywhere
on our glasses and
we're going to look
around and everything
is going to have text
all over it. I think
I'm waiting for that.
>> With enthusiasm?
>> Sure; sure.
(Chuckles)
>> Yeah,
I think there's
always this hunger fo
r more and different.
But I do think that
that paradigm of the information
landscape from that
conference, what was it,
30 years ago,
was like a
profound moment. Because
it wasn't just layers
of text that were
parallel to the screen. But
the fact of the moving
like this was mind
blowing. Because it was
just taking the perspective
in a different way.
And that it was live text.
It wasn't pictures of text.
It was actual
language that could
be edited.
>> I think, also,
a lot of what
you see in the advertising
and sort of
the versions of this that
are really pervasive are
really kind of the
side effect of it.
You love when type moves
around in 3D
on a screen We're
very drawn to it.
And we're really drawn
to language and things like
that. But I think the
fundamental kinds of
issues that Muriel and
VLW were going after
as far as
how do you actually move
through a space of information?
How do you
actually interact with it?
understand this? We're still
a long ways off from
actually fixing a lot
more of those core ideas.
And how do we spend
more time kind of
focused on unpacking some
of those issues that they
had just kind of
started to
scratch the
surface of?
>> I think
sometimes when the argument
of how she progressed
from book design
with the VLW, that
it was a limit.
The book was too still.
All kinds of things that
stayed -- were kind of
intervening on the
kinds of movement
that she wanted.
But I actually think
actually some of that
stillness remained in the
design. And I think that's
what's been lost. This kind
of gap or temporal
gap between the acquisition
of data and the
plane of discovery. And
those have been compressed.
And here with her
work, you always had
that -- the time to
do that. And that temporal
kind of extension and
duration has been rapidly
closing. And I think that
that's an issue or
what gives her work
that kind of interest
or depth I think
>> Yeah, I
think when I look
at her --
at Muriel Cooper's later
work when it's the screen-based
work and the digital work,
it always really seems
to have like if not
a literary root to it,
at least it's sort
of thought -- you understand
that the information is
meant to be understood and
interpreted. And I think if
you sort of want
to take a writeup of
the presenter day, you know,
one of the reasons that
we have this crisis of
what is truth and what
is fake news is that information
comes to people
from all sorts of different
angles, links to things
>> It always looks good.
>> Yeah. And
things are linked
off of things.
And they all -- we
can admit, they are all sort
of coming out of the
same pipe. And people
make up their own
minds about what's true
or not. And I think
that's sort of what is the
authorial -- the authority that
authors bring to things.
No mistake those words
I think have the
same root Which
the difference between
the treatise and
a pile of manuscript I think
is sort of a little bit
about -- you know, that
gap defines the
confusion that pervades
the world today.
>> Good.
>> Can I ask a question?
>> Please.
>> Go ahead, Ricky.
>> (Off microphone).
>>
Yeah.
>> (Off microphone) and
that conversation was
made (inaudible) of having
spoke to each other
(off microphone).
>> Yeah.
>> It was a live event.
>> Yeah, so Ricky points out,
if you didn't hear it, it was
really an attempt to create a
conversation on the page, a
conversation with the text,
and sort of the ideal almost as
Talmudic commentary on
a set text.
And I would guess
there are some
authors that actually don't
like that, they don't
want to have
a conversation, they
just want --
>>
Yeah, leave
me alone.
>> Yeah, leave me
alone and let me just
say my piece and read
all the way through. And that wasn't
Muriel's point of view. Muriel's
point of view, I think, was
to enable people to
access text in a lot
of different
ways and to interact
with it actively.
>> Yeah.
>> So is there one big lesson
that we can learn from Muriel
that would solve our problems
as they
are currently
developed? Ellen?
>> I think what was really
driving so much of her work
was the desire to break down the
mediation between authorship and
getting it out there.
And the idea that
you could have direct access
to both the content and
its delivery. I think
that was just a driving
thing. That she wanted to
get rid of that person
you have to call up
and ask, oh, I have a
typo, will you fix it?
>> Yeah.
>> Right? People
don't want to have
to do that.
They don't want to have
to call Michael Bierut and
say, fix my typo.
They just want to be
able to fix it. And
I think that desire to
get rid of
that mediation was really
profound for her.
And it's really important
to me as an
author who also uses InDesign.
I want to
fix my own typos,
thank you, Muriel
>> Ben, Aron?
>> So most
of my work is about
sort of understanding --
working with
information. And basically
this idea
of there's this mess
of information out there.
And that design is
essentially the lens through
which the -- the
only lens through which we're
going to get
understanding out of it. As
far as I'm concerned,
Muriel really represents sort
of a patron saint of
that type of thinking
And that way of
how an individual actually
interacts with information as
meditated by code and
by the computer as a
digital tool. It's remarkable.
>> Yeah, for me, I
think it's that communication is
not just conveying information.
But as I said,
exposing us to the
risk of experience.
And that it's --
as you pointed out --
a conversation, an encounter
And those kinds of
things are precious. And
need to be fostered.
And that illegibles
and incommunicabilities are
not external areas
but they are
generated internally. And those
are productive of some
of our most
interesting encounters. So when
those texts are
shifting, there are
certain points where polemicist
tap-ins, where it
erases information and just
doesn't reveal it. And
those are important
points. And I think
those opacities, blind spots,
illegibles are kind of
being wiped out and
we need to find new
ways of preserving those
kinds of things, difficulties.
>> I would like
to thank our panel, Aron
Vinegar, Ben Fry, Ellen Lupton.
Please join me.
(Applause).
>> Thank you very much.
>> That was good.
>> Thank you.
[Music].
>> This is an unscheduled
introduction because I'm not
supposed to be doing it.
But I
thought you would like
to know something
which John might not tell
you. When we opened up
the Media Lab in 1985,
one of the less
colorful groups was an
advanced television program,
which was a
very engineering approach
to high definition
and stuff like
that. And there was
this young graduate student
from
electrical engineering
named John Maeda
who was awfully
unhappy with his 6'2"
Germanic heel clicking advisor.
And he says, oh, I'm
so unhappy. And I really
want to be an artist.
And for one reason
or another, he drops out.
He goes to Japan.
I think his parents
may have blamed me or
other people. But they
weren't happy. And John
goes to Japan, end of
story Nine years later,
Muriel dies 1994, May
28th And after recovering,
which you can't
really do very easily, we
set up a search, an
international search, for who
could replace Muriel Cooper.
Well, the answer is
nobody can replace
Muriel Cooper. But who
could we get that would
be somewhat in the
same domain? And this was
not a fixed, wired search.
This was a real,
honest global search. And
boop, John Maeda appears
from Japan and
applies, comes here, gives
the talk and won
that search handsdown.
And came back as
a faculty member, which I'm
sure his parents also
loved us for
now that you are
back So John?
(Applause).
>> Thank you.
Wow, that was
a nice introduction.
(Chuckles).
>> I am a dropout.
>> It is true. Also
a faculty dropout now, too. So
I have a few presentation slides.
Because I thought it
should be visual. I arrived
roughly three hours ago.
And began in
the lobby to
make a presentation.
And I was trying to
understand what I could say to
all of you. Because I
knew you would all be
here. So first of all,
who knew Muriel, raise your
hand. So those who didn't
know Muriel, did her work
change you? In any
tiny way. Those who didn't
know her. You didn't know
her but it just kind
of hit you. Grace Colby
over there, just threw a
button at me. It changed
her life as a student.
And I see so many
students here of Muriel's. You'll
get to see Dave Small
later, who -- where is Dave?
Dave is going to be
talking later. Dave was
that sort of magical
link between what Muriel's
group did and what my
group did. And I feel
very lucky. Okay. Let's bring
up the information. Okay. I
don't know -- I don't
have a fancy Pentagram
video. Oh, video problem. Oh,
no problem Okay. So, first
of all, I want to
know something that Ben
Fry didn't mention. Where is
Ben? Ben is over
there. Thank you. Press play.
It will come. Ben, where
are you, Ben? Ben,
you're back there. So I
arrived here at the Media Lab
And I had to like
find students. That's something
you have to do
when you become a
professor. And I had no
experience doing that. So what
I began to do
was I was surfing all
kind of Web sites looking for
people Kind of like in
X-Men or something. Trying
to find the mutants that
can do the visual
and can do the code
And I located this one
person named Ben Fry, who
was at this nominal
company called Netscape. They
were trying to
make this thing. It
was never going to came
off, whatever. But somehow
I convinced Ben to leave
that early stage startup, sorry,
Ben, to come to
the Media Lab
(Chuckles).
>> And also
like a year later a
gentleman appeared named Casey Reas
who told me
really wanted to come here.
He was a graphic designer.
But didn't know how
to code. I said, well, you're
going to have to learn
how to code. He said, what
do I have to learn? I
said you have to know C++,
you have to
know OpenGL He said
uh-huh, uh-huh, uh-huh.
And wrote it down in
his notebook. I've got to tell
you, I tell all kind of
people that same
thing and they go, uh-huh,
uh-huh, and never come back.
(Chuckles).
>> But a year later,
Casey shows up with his
laptop. And he says, hi.
I said, you came back.
He says, yeah, after I met
you, I quit my job.
And he was at a
Dotcom thing, a really good
one. And he quit his job
and began focusing
on computation and it
blew me away. S
o I just want to
say that this place is very
special. And this place really
happened because of a
few people in this
room. But most certainly
with Nicholas over here,
who had this vision that
like a George Clooney
style Ocean's Eleven something
that this mix of
people could create something.
And I think
that catalyzing force is
so powerful. Because yesterday
I was at Sponsor
Day. You know, Sponsor
Day. It's like special
private viewing of things.
So I was blown away.
First of all, I
was saying Neri Oxman's
stuff, it was like amazing.
I was sitting over
there. I said, oh, Neri,
you're like blowing my mind.
Like, whoa, you can
do that now? And I
also saw Glorianna, Circle of
Life Cameo. And Joe
Paradiso was showing his
like weird stuff, which
is always good. It's
like, you know, a
lot of bass and
mysterious and sensors everywhere.
And I saw also --
I'm turning to my left and
there's like Hughes legs, like,
okay, cool, right. And
then I saw Chris Shamat
(phonetic). Chris is the
person who invented the
car navigation system. If
you imagine like the
Media Lab saw all
of these things, had
these ideas, they were
outlandish at the time. Why
would you ever need your
car to tell you
where to go? Right? And
of course, Hiroshi Ishii, I
got to see his lab.
Hiroshi makes everything like
vibrate and shake and
whatever. So I had
a great time. I felt
very Media Laby. Wow, all of
the stuff you can see
here. But I came here
today for Muriel. I also
saw the special like
branded floor. I was a
little bit early. I don't
have a place here anymore.
So I hung out in
the lobby, just sitting there in
the Wiesner sort of like
special place Who knew
Jerry Wiesner? Who knew
this person? So an
amazing figure of MIT
Stood for world peace,
like really important stuff,
right? So I just hung
out there and worked. And
as I worked there, it's
great because when you're in
this little place, suddenly you
see all of the
details. Because I've been
here like four or five
times. But by sitting
there, I also looked at
a video conference and I'm
like, wait, there's a
picture. And I said this
picture. And this is like
a really good picture. This
is like a good picture,
right? And when I saw
this picture, it reminded me
of what, to me, MIT
meant. Because I really had
never heard of design
when I came to
MIT. I was a classical
engineering student. My parents
didn't have much money
or education. So just
coming here was the
whole goal. By the time
I got here, I wasn't sure
what to do. But I
remembered looking at the
Media Lab and thinking,
well, that's a really
weird place. That
seems unconventional -- very
impractical. You know,
like it's a big
format. It's got images everywhere.
I don't understand it.
Let's make it cheaper and
simpler. It's like I didn't
know what that was.
And I was talking to
the person at the front.
There was a person from
member relations.
And --
Sharon.
>> Who is
she? What does
she do?
>> I just recently found out.
>> What did you find out?
>> Oh my God.
>> She knows everything
in the Media Lab. She's
at the front desk.
So I said, who
is Muriel Cooper? And
she wasn't sure.
So we cut the
camera then. And then
we did Cut 2.
>> Famous person.
>> Famous person?
>> With a wonderful legacy.
>> How does someone
have a wonderful legacy?
What's the secret? >
> Passion, enthusiasm, probably a
little bit of arrogance. >>
Hmmm . . .
>> And persistence.
>> What's your name?
>> I'm Sharon.
>> Applause for Sharon. (Applause).
>> She just
kind of nailed it. And
I thought about these things.
These four
words. And I
thought about passion.
And to Nicholas' point,
you know, I did
have this very special professor
here at the Media
Lab who made my life a
little bit difficult. In retrospect
I'm very grateful,
of course, everything is
better in hindsight.
But I decided to leave.
But I didn't know what to
do. And Muriel told me
to go to art school.
And it was the best
advice to give to me.
She said that I wouldn't
learn what I was wanting
to learn at a
technical school. Because I
had done all of
the technical education. The
problem with engineering education
is you learn how
to build anything.
But you don't know what to
build. Or why to build it.
And so -- but in art
school, it really changed my
life really. So I thank
Muriel. Now, this word,
enthusiasm, is interesting.
Because something about
enthusiasm is
something that you might
have as a rising
person, someone who is
going to figure stuff
out. And enthusiastic people
tend to need
aspirational people. Like how
many people had a
hero? Come on. Who
had a hero? Heroes.
So that hero was
someone that was aspirational.
And my friend told me
recently, Jessie, my dear friend,
an artist, told me
how aspiration and
inspiration are two different
things. Aspiration is
what you're trying to
see and you understand.
Inspiration is what
awakens inside you and
is the fire that someone
else gave you through
having that aspirational being
So I remember like
leaving here. Not sure
what to do. In Japan.
Rebuilt my career as a
designer. I came back to t
he computer. And figured out
that the skill I had
to make code, to Ben's
point, I knew what to
make suddenly. It was so
much easier. And I
began publishing things in
Japan And I made this
little book called "The
Reactive Square," which is
10 squares that respond
to sound delivered
on a floppy disk. I
know, very ancient. But I
remember like, this kind of
feels right. You know?
And I remember emailing Muriel
and saying, hey, I
think I figured it out.
And she wrote back to me
and said, show me. And
then a month later, she
passed away. So I remember
when I heard there
was this call for someone
to somehow come here, I
thought, I can never
do that. That's impossible.
But I would love to
show my respect. And
what happened is the day
before I came to the
Media Lab to give a
faculty talk, I was visiting
this idol that I had,
Paul Rand. Again, I didn't
know about design when I
came to MIT. Once I
saw the Media Lab's
world, I thought, I want
to learn a little bit
more about design. And I
found a book by Paul
Rand by accident in the
MIT's Rotch visual library. I
don't know if it's still
here. But I was like, whoa,
what is this book? This
book is so fascinating. Ah,
design Really interesting. I think
I want to do
this. Well, anyways, years
later in Japan the Paul
Rand of Japan, Ikko
Tanaka, befriended me. He
said, hey, if you're going
to the United States,
you should visit my friend,
Paul Rand. I said, cool. So
I went to visit Mr.
Rand. And the next day
was my faculty talk. So what
a good day to do
like any job talk, right?
I was like so happy. I
like met my dream person.
So when I came
here, I wasn't nervous luckily.
I should have been
nervous. But anyways, that was
a big moment. So when
I arrived at MIT,
I asked Nicholas if
we could bring Paul Rand.
And I remember Nicholas
said, Paul Rand, is he
still alive? Is he still around?
I said, oh, yeah, he's
around. And we were
worried if people would come
to see Paul Rand
talk. And also Paul made
it much more difficult by
saying he wanted to
speak at 10 a.m.
And Nicholas might not
remember this. But Nicholas
said, no, no one is going
to come at 10 a.m. 4 p.m.
Have him come at 4 p.m.
I said, can you
come at 4 p.m.? Professor
Negroponte -- he said, no,
I'm coming at 10 a.m.
(sic). If no one is going to
show up at 4 p.m. (sic),
I never wanted to talk
to them anyways. So he
showed up at 10 a.m.
And I'm sure
Nicholas remembers the auditorium
was packed. It was
standing room only.
It was an incredible
outpouring for Mr. Rand
and design in general,
which was exciting. Arrogance.
I loved that
moment when she says,
arrogance. And everyone kind
of like bristled,
like, yeah, but there's a
Bob Sutton book about the
no assholes. But wait
a second. I don't
understand this. Well, it's a
fact that artists might
appear arrogant. But as --
when I ran the School of
Design, I was able to
work with many artists. And
I found this one thing
I didn't understand at
the beginning. I used to
visit all of the lunchrooms
and bring my food
around and sit with students
randomly to see if they
would let me sit
with them. Sometimes they
would say, no, no,
don't sit with us.
Sometimes, come own here.
But one day there
was this one young
woman who said, come here.
Come. I was like, oh,
no. She wants to sit
with me So I sat
with her. And she was
saying, you know, I'm a
freshman. Oh, no, complaints,
it's coming Something is
coming. I'm a
freshman. And it was
really hard that first semester.
You know, I come
from the Midwest. This is
all new to me. I
didn't understand it. Didn't
understand the teachers. It was
just so hard. Every day
I just didn't know
what to do. And she
said, no I'm in the second
term. And I know where
things are. I know what
kind of questions to ask.
It's all working really
well. But I have a
confession to make. I said,
oh, no, confession. I have
to confess that I don't
feel alive. And so I
remember like walking back to
my office and the
elevator opened and my friend
Jessie, she was the
Provost at the time.
She was right there. I
said, Jessie, an interesting
thing happened to me.
I was sitting with this
young woman. And she
said this thing. And Jessie
looked at me and said,
well, of course. She's
an artist. An artist
doesn't feel alive unless they
feel the struggle. It's
through that struggle that
they feel alive. So it
may look like arrogance.
But it's that strength to
be different that I see
is there. And lastly,
persistence. What a good one
to end on. Think about
it. I mean, when
you tell like younger people
today that there was a
time when there was
this like dot matrix typeface,
not like an anti-alias version
of it, but like 5
dots by 7 dots was
all you got. And I'm
now a Product Manager/Design
Lead where I'm at a
company where you tell people,
do this No, that's
not the way you have to
do it. Do it this way.
It's better. No, I think it's
good this way. It gives
me a sense of how easier
it is now compared to
when Muriel was able
to convince people that
maybe you need this
thing called Helvetica. Maybe
it has to be anti-alias
so it looks much
more smooth to the
eye. Pleasurable. So that kind
of persistence, I can't
imagine how hard it was
for her and the team back
then to do what has
happened. But look how
amazing information is today
on our devices.
So persistence Good persistence. So
all I can say now is
I am at the very
end And I'm 0:0 seconds
and I want to leave
with this thought that
Muriel was one of the
great teachers. And all of
you are teachers in
different ways, too.
So please consider
yourselves as intellectual
philanthropists. People that can
give this away to
other people. Think
about opportunities. I used to
raise money so I will
do a thing for MIT
Press. If you have not
bought this book or aren't
buying it yet, buy many
for your friends. Because
it's a way to
carry Muriel's legacy forward.
Thank you.
(Applause).
[Music].
>> I'm going to
introduce you guys. So
give me two seconds
Because I also have to
say one other word, which
you guys may not know.
But there's apparently a
new fund that's been
created by the Wade family
I believe
it's Emily and Jeptha
-- is anybody
here from the Wade family?
No? Anyway, it's a new
fund for the MIT Press
which will bear Muriel's
name. And its purpose,
as I understand it,
is to help make the
art and architecture and design
books easier to do
and subventure them and do
whatever. And yours is the
first. So we not
only want to hear about
the book. But you should
know it's the first of
the Muriel Cooper fund I
guess it's a little nepotistic
for it to be funding
the Muriel book.
But at any
rate, please come.
(Applause).
>> Thank you. Thank
you, Nicholas. My name
is Rob Wiesenberger
This is David
Reinfurt. We are co-authors
of this book,
which we hope
you'll see soon,
entitled "Muriel Cooper."
We just wanted
to make a
few very basic
observations about the
book, about its structure,
about the intent
behind it. Before that
we wanted to thank the
MIT Press for its
enthusiasm about the project,
for investing in it.
Thank the Media Lab
for hosting. And thank so
many people in this room
from the family and
the colleagues and friends
of Cooper's. The archivists,
the librarians, all
of these people who helped
to make this material come
alive for us. So
just a couple of
words on this book. The
first observation is pretty
straightforward about its scale.
And hopefully you'll appreciate
it. It's a
big book. And we were
really happy to see that,
this book can stand up
beside Cooper's two great
tomes the Bauhaus of
1969, after which this
book takes some inspiration
visually. And "Learning from
Las Vegas" of
1972, which is mercifully back
in print. So we really
like that this book
can hold its own.
This book dedicated to
Cooper. Beside those two
great tomes and this book
is also about the person
who helped take us
beyond the book so
it feels appropriate. When you
get into the book,
you'll see that the epigraph
to start off with is
a sort of confession of
Cooper's. And she says, I
guess I'm never sure that
print is truly linear. I
print is truly linear. And
she said this in the
'90s when she's already working
in the digital realm. And
to us, it seems
like a nice way to
start a book. Because it's
kind of a statement of
ambivalence. It's a statement
very typically of Cooper's.
It's a statement
of ambivalence. It's a
statement of possibility, as
well. She's just gotten
done of explaining the
specificity of the printed
book versus the
possibilities of the digital.
And then she back tracks
and says, actually I
guess I'm never sure that
print is truly linear. And
so it seemed like an
appropriately self-reflexive way to
start a book But
also appropriate to
her, who felt, even as
she moved into the digital
world, that the book
was a specific kind of
technology. The Codex book had
its own set of
possibilities. And simultaneity for
her versus linear, she
really strove for
simultaneity. Not that you start
here and end here. But
that in all of her,
whether it was a highly
layered image that comes at
you all at once or
can be accessed in different
ways or a video disk
that you can skip
around based on your own
path or the hyperlinking of
the world we now
live in, simultaneity non-linear
was so important to
Cooper. And I think
she showed books can do
that. And so we wanted
to start with this very
equivocal and self-reflexive
acknowledgement of the
power that books
still actually hold that
she showed to us. Very
sort of basic observation.
But in the Table of
Contents, we separated out --
there's a text portion
and an image portion. And that's
the structure of the Bauhaus book
that Cooper designed, as well. She
inherited it from this German
predecessor. But we both
wrote essays on both her
early and late work
respectively, her work in
print and software respectively.
And they are
essays, they are attempts,
they are brief. And then
we show you the
work. And we really
wanted to foreground the work
and let people enter
in either direction. And
we think that, you know,
at different times maybe
the text will be
galvanizing for people, her words
At other times, the
images will be. At other times still
the images may feel dated and then
they will feel new again. So we
wanted to provide these two ways of
accessing it And you'll see
there are these two texts
and then there are
these three sections
We call them portfolio
sections And they
respectively, they represent her
work. They are design
and teaching and
research. And they were
successive categories in her
career. She did
them one after another.
Of course they bleed into
one another. They are
not such crisp distinctions.
But the point that I
wanted to make that
struck me -- that
struck us about Cooper was
that design and teaching
and research, we didn't
write those categories. That she
did. And I think
we have heard tonight
that her career intersected
with a lot of
interesting people It's actually
Paul Rand, who we
just heard about, who
recommended her for a job
at the MIT Press. It's,
you know, the great
design luminary Georgia
Kalpesh (phonetic) before
that who brought
her onto MIT. She
designed the Bauhaus book
when Herbert Bayer, the
great Bauhaus master, wasn't
available. She was at
the MIT Media Lab
with a whole set of luminaries, many
of whom are in this room. And yet
she designed and redesigned
her own career in
really interesting ways.
So these chapters, design
and teaching and research,
we quote her in
the book as saying, I
very deliberately decided I no
longer wanted to be
a designer in a
traditional sense. And she
uses the word deliberately
about three times in a
sentence or two And that
idea of the deliberate,
the purposive, the intentional,
that she was forging
her way, creating
careers in fields that simply
didn't exist with a lot
of assists from the
brilliant minds around her.
But that she wrote
these chapters. So the
last thing I wanted to
say is, you know, it's striking
when you hear about --
when we hear about
Muriel tonight, I mean,
we didn't know her
personally. And we're very aware
of that. I mean, I
was 10 when she
died. You will --
David will tell his passing
connection. But we didn't
know her. And we respect
all of the help of those
who did. And we want
to provide this way
in. And it's striking
that she's simultaneously by
everyone's account this
kind of firecracker,
this incredible personality.
So idiosyncratic and yet is
not well known and didn't
really have the time
in her own life
because she was working so
hard. Often behind the
scenes. To really consolidate her
work in a clear way
and say, this is my
career. And it probably
wasn't even in her character
to talk about herself
or her work in that
way to her great credit. So
this book is that attempt
to, with a little distance,
to consolidate her career and
look at it with
some perspective. So we hope
you enjoy it. And with
that I wanted to
turn it over to David.
(Applause).
>> Okay. I did
not know Muriel Cooper, either,
as Rob made clear.
I did, however, in I think it
was January of 1995, I was
a young designer working in
New York, not knowing what I
was doing. And I thought
it would be fantastic to
come and study at the
Media Lab and I arranged
to make a visit up here
in January of 1995 to
visit the VLW. And at
that point, I saw some
of the work on screen.
Actually Lisa Strausfeld was
a student here at the
time. And I remember
thinking it was fantastic
that she was an architect
before. But when I
saw this work, then the
next time I ended up
not coming back to
Graduate School because I went
to go work at IDO
in San Francisco. In
1995. And I went
to work for Geita Solomon
(phonetic), who was a
student from the Media
Lab and who had
finished And what was
striking at the time out
in San Francisco, I was
hired as an interaction
designer which was quite
a new field at that
time, Muriel Cooper's work,
and specifically the
information landscapes, were
presented as kind of
primary material as I
was starting to understand
what might happen on
a screen and its relationship
to design So that was
soon -- not so long
after the TEDTalk in
Monterey, which we have
heard described a couple
of times tonight from
people who were there
and who organized it.
Anyway, when I first
saw this -- saw the
information landscapes work, it
was first as printed images
in an article by Janet
Abrams in an I.D.
Magazine I think. And I
later saw it moving not
very long after that. And
I was struck as
a designer with the way
in which familiar typographic
relationships, which conveyed
meaning, which usually
were done with
bold or size or
two dimensional approaches, seemed
to be completely
intact but just another
dimension was added to it.
And of course that's
a third dimension. But
it's also a dimension
of time more
consequentially here. And I
recognized this as work
that was happening
on the screen that opened
up a whole new set
of possibilities. But I
recognized it coming specifically
from like a design
place. It was about
ten years before I
came into contact with her
work again. And during
that time, I was shocked that
a lot of the -- a lot
of this work I didn't hear
discussed within graphic
design or interaction
design. Extensively
during that time period
Maybe it was my
own removed from whatever
scenes were talking about it.
But it was just absent.
And in 2005, I came
back to MIT and I
was doing some graphic design
work with the Center
for Advanced Visual Studies, which
was at the end of
its kind of run.
And I stumbled into
a closest up there, which
was filled with posters.
They were just stacked
one on top of
each other. Absolutely fabulous, f
antastic things Very excited
to find these things.
Started to pull them
out. And at the same time
I found a -- like a
CV from Muriel Cooper at
the Center for Advanced
Visual Studies from I
think 1971. And I
expected that these posters
were likely designed by
Muriel Cooper. I
was quickly corrected as
many of them weren't.
But what I recognized
in these was a similar
approach to what I had
seen in the information
landscapes, which seemed to
be a kind of
deep investment in the
temporal aspect of making
a piece of graphic
design work. So whether
it's the rotations that are
in the print on the left,
which use the kind of
staging of a printing press
as a way to generate
form or on the right,
which is made with a
split fountain, which is another
way of kind of
using the tools to
produce the graphic effect
essentially. Now, in the
book, these are several
spreads from the book. In
the book, we've made
a real attempt to
show the things that we
found, pieces of Muriel
Cooper's work, and her
students' work and ancillary
materials as much
as artifacts as possible.
So you see something
like the mechanical
artwork for the MIT
Press logo, which is
presented with the masking
tape on it. And the
sketch -- the original sketch that
looks like it led to
this proposal for a logo
on the left. These are
largely left unframed by
kind of writing essentially.
And the idea as Rob
described, as well, was
to make this a kind
of source book for other
people to continue this
work. It seemed --
given our distance from the
material and the real
situation, it also seemed
like the most productive
positive thing we
could do was present this
work so that other people
can take up the
project. So that other
people can get excited
about this singular
collection of design --
of design. And continue
it forward, whether
through research or taking
ideas, et cetera. Now, you
know, it gets sewn
up in this giant --
in this rather large book
which is very beautifully
produced by the MIT Press.
We're thrilled with the way
that it came out.
But on the spine of
this book is -- down in
the bottom, you know, you
don't have to see --
is a piece of Muriel Cooper's
work that we all know
well. But seen in situ,
not removed. So this would have
to be one of my
favorite pieces of graphic
design. And the way
in which it oscillates
between a kind
of figurative typographic thing
and machine readable
graphic. But seeing it do
the type of work it's
meant to do, which is
identify this book as MIT
Press. And I just think we
-- both of us feel
quite honored to have
it published by MIT,
given the subject matter
that's in it. So we hope
you'll look at it. Enjoy it.
And make some work from it.
(Applause).
[Music]
>> Hello, everybody, I'm
Todd Machover. And we
have a wonderful panel
here to talk
about Muriel as
a teacher.
And I think we'll
have an opportunity to
talk about the culture
of the Visible Language
Workshop, as well. We
have Ron McNeill, who
was really Muriel's partner
for the entire time
that the Visible Language
Workshop ran. And really
ran it together. So we're
going to hear from
Ron about how it started
and what it meant and
how it worked Lisa
Strausfeld, who was mentioned,
started out as an
architect but came
and studied design with
Muriel in the Visible
Language Workshop as
one of the
world's most prominent designers.
Worked with Pentagram
independently and now is
at the New York
University. And David Small,
who, when he started working
with Muriel, told me just
before -- I hadn't
remembered this -- hadn't
done any design work at
all and found his
way to Muriel through
photography and became a
designer in Muriel's
tutelage, started a small
design firm which is
one of the most
prominent design firms in the
world. So we'll talk to
them in just a
second. I just wanted to
make a couple of comments
first. One is that I
was one of the very
first people to be hired
at the Media Lab. People
like Muriel and Nicholas
were at MIT before the
Media Lab. But when
the building opened, I was
one of the first people
to come here. And
Muriel was one of
the very kindest people to
everybody but I remember
certainly to me. I came
here. I was 30 years old
I think. I was a
musician, an artist. And
Muriel understood that it wasn't
to easy to be
an artist in a culture,
even the Media Lab. But a
culture like MIT. So she
never said too much about
it. But she always found
time to check in
just to see how I was
doing. To see if things were
okay. And to see if
that part of my
creative work here was being
nurtured She really cared.
And now one of the things
that I'm proudest of of all
of the things that I
do is I'm the Muriel
Cooper professor here at MIT.
And not a day goes
by when I don't think
about somehow trying to live
up to her example as
a designer and an artist
and as a mentor. And
as somebody who helps
to shape this place. And
as a human being. Because
she really was as
close to the soul of
the Media Lab as anybody. And
I'll just tell you one
little story before I turn
it over to our panelists.
Ron will recognize this.
But you two won't. It has
to do with her as a
teacher and as a mentor.
So in the early days
of the Media Lab, the
place was small enough that
when we would go
through the admissions process
to pick our
students, we would actually all
sit around a big table.
We would do this
a few times iteratively. And
all of the folders for
all of the students
would be on the table.
And the place was small
enough that we would
all read the folders
for everybody. And we would
pass them around the
table. And the idea was
we would have three or
four of these meetings.
And each of the
meetings you were supposed to
make a shorter and
shorter list. You would
read the folders and
you're supposed to say,
okay, there are 50 people
who want to be in my
group and now my job
is to figure out the 30
And now it's the 10. And
then -- and every time we
would make a list on
the board. And Nicholas, you
know, runs a pretty
tight ship. And he would
make sure that every time
we would kind of
whittle down the list. We
would even write the names
on the board of
our short list. It's an
important thing to do. One
of the biggest things is
to pick the right students
here. I'll never forget, all
of us, we wanted to
follow what Nicholas wanted
us to do. So we
would whittle down our
lists And we would get
to the second, third --
we would get to the
finalist. And here are the
two people I really want
to admit. And we
would get to Muriel
and say, okay, Muriel, what's
your short list? She
would say, well, I've
got 20 people. Nicholas would
go, what, 20 people,
no. I need more time.
Just 20 people. So part
of it was the Chinese
menu thing about maybe not
being able to decide but
I really think it's
because she took so
much time to think about
every single one of
those applicants And to
figure out where there
was something special
which might not be so
obvious in the normal way
of judging a student
and to figure out not
only who she wanted to
nurture but what kind of
group she could bring
together to make the
Visible Language Workshop
special. It was really
amazing. It drove Nicholas crazy.
But she was also
the only one I think
it's because you were such
close friends but also
you respected each other so
much she was the only
one he would let
get away with that. But
she always did. But here
are the kind of people
she admitted. I would like
to maybe start with Ron.
Just -- because you
were here at the
very beginning. Tell us
how the Visible Language
Workshop started Why
it started. How
it worked.
>> I thought that
it would be nice
to see the very,
very grubby beginning of
her third act where
we started the VLW.
So the VLW's story
starts in the early 1970s.
Way before the Internet.
Way before the
PC. With me, a
photographer turned print maker.
In my work space
on the 4th floor of Building
5 in the Department of
Architecture. Slating over
a hot offset press.
Teaching a class
in non-silver
image making called
photographics. So
before I met her, Muriel
and I shared a friend,
Tom Norton. Who told her
about my offset press. And
as it turned out, Muriel
was looking to start
ACT III of her career
outside of MIT Press. So
you might imagine that
Muriel was visualizing something
like this when Tom
told her about my
Press. But of course
you would be wrong. Because
that's what she was
imagining The scene of
a group of eager,
very smart future designer
disrupters with Muriel as
the lioness den mother
teaching them in the
ways of disruption. After
she came on board
officially what Muriel soon
created was an
iconic humanities distribution
class called messages
and means. It
was consistently oversubscribed
because it asked
students who normally spent
all day thinking abstractly
to connect their
imagination and their
hands in creative exploration.
And of course,
many of them had never,
ever even tried to do
that before. So Muriel felt
strongly that the author
and maker should be the
same person. Or more
practically, back then, that
the gap between the
author and the maker
should be collapsed as
much as possible. And in
search of the closest
thing to an interactive
experience possible, Muriel threw
out all of the
then conventions of reproduction
technology to get us
as close to a
hands-on interactive design
production experience as
was possible.
Often going from concept
to mask to plate to
printed piece in one
class. So she called
this iconic class project
a rotation. Where the
students would use square
paper, create the mask
by working directly
on acetate with press type.
But use only one plate
and rotate the paper
between color changes. Notice
the female press operator.
So sadly very
few of these pieces
have actually survived. And the
ones that I'm going
to show you are not
fabulous. But, you know, they
are still I think worth
seeing. Here is the
split fountain. Very popular. The
third color. Here is
another approach. And yet
another. So she also
inherited a basic visual
literacy freshman seminar
called creative seeing. She
had 3 assistants
in a class of
60 bright-eyed bushy-tailed
students. And here they are
taking part in a sky
art event So here they
are mapping their physical,
social and family
relationships. And then
below exploring instant
reproduction technologies. And
of course they explored
the book form.
Just a few examples
of probably an incredibly
varied class. So our
computational explorations
started in earnest when I got
a grant to
build a billboard painting
machine. Which you see
here. It worked well
for about an afternoon
(Chuckles)
But the part
of the project
that really
excited both Muriel and
me was the interactive
color computer graphic
image and text editing
system that was needed in
order to create the
images for the
billboard painter. So after
a three-year collaboration
between many grad and
undergrad assistants, we had
one of the first
artist workstations capable
of synthesizing image and
type in near real-time.
Sadly the crude
image type handling capability
was a constant
frustration for Muriel. But
it was also extremely hard
to fix because the
CPU that we were using
was about as fast as
the fast MacIntosh. So
there was a time just
before -- sort of the
middle of the project, just
about every morning I would
come in and see a
new function or a new
image added by one
of the student artists that
were informed by work
by other students that
had been done previous
days. The 300 megabyte
image disk space was
a big canvas that let
everybody else share ideas
in a free and easy
way. Of course Muriel was not
off limits as a subject.
So when we first moved
into the Media Lab, the
tools were still just as
frustrating for Muriel as
ever. But things began to
change for the good
when David Small, Suguru
Ishizaki and Mrs. Strausfeld
and earlier Renn Sen
(phonetic) began the
information landscape work.
Over to Dave.
>> Okay David, do you
want to take it from
there? That's a good introduction
(Applause).
>> Thank you. So
as I think has
been mentioned multiple times,
I was involved in that
famous couple of days in
Monterey at the TED5
conference. And I
was that waiter
that Nicholas described
that I thought we
were going to go
to Monterey, we
were going to speak on
the second day and then
was going to see Big
Sur and go to the
aquarium. It was going to
be like a fantastic thing.
Instead Muriel angled from
like the moment we landed
to get us almost
like the very last spot
on the schedule. And we
spent those three days,
me hunched over the
computer, and her changing
her mind over and
over and over. So if we
can switch to the -- to
my phone here. One thing
that's always bothered me
about that piece is we
really didn't have at
the time any way of
documenting it except to make
a kind of videotape
which was always so
like fuzzy and wasn't alive.
And two years ago
when the Museum of
Modern Art acquired this
piece for their
collection, I said, what
do you mean acquire the
piece? You want what?
What is it? They said,
well, I guess the videotape.
I said, okay, but maybe
we can do more. And
there's a group here at the
Media Lab -- there's a
lot of different research
groups. But there's a
group called Nexus which
manages the network and all
of the computers. And I
wrote to them, I
said, do you have our
backups from 23 years ago?
They were like, oh,
no, they are online. I'll
just email you. So all
of the original source code
was there. It's still
there. And I inveigled my
husband to port everything
to the phone over the
past couple of weeks. So this
is a facsimile of the
presentation that was given
at TED from the
original source code and
this is unlike -- unlike
the videotape this is really
what it felt like. So
imagine this. I can see
it from this angle and I
can see it from this
angle. But then you
have Muriel over your shoulder
saying, should it be
learning and common
sense? Should it be
. . .
(Chuckles).
>> I don't know
about that color. It was
like changing over and over
and over again up
until like an hour or
two before we went on stage.
It was like
one of the most terrifying
things in my life.
And then she talked I had
no idea going into it what
she was going to say.
She never made a note
or jotted anything down of what
she was going to say.
She just talked and
I latched onto everything that
she said as much as
I could
and tried to keep
up with her.
So anyway, just --
I just wanted to
-- I didn't want
people to not have sort
of a feel for what this
actually was So the end
of the little story, hopefully
not the end-end of the
story but the end for
today was that we
submitted it to the Apple
App Store last night
because I was hoping I
could tell everyone to go
to the App Store and
download it. And they
kicked it out. They
said it had insufficient
functionality. Or -- sorry;
minimal functionality. I'm like,
yeah, it doesn't
do anything.
(Chuckles).
>> But yeah, so
it's just about going down
and down, tighter and tighter.
And then this
idea, too, if you could
look at something one way
but then maybe
you could look at
it a different way.
You could go back to this
way and then this way. So
to me, I just sat
there for weeks flipping back
and forth like, now I
can read this. The
other thing is still on the
screen. But now I can read
that. But now I can
read this. And it was
just like one of the most
exciting times of my life
to have been involved in
this. And I'm just happy to
be able to share it
with everyone here.
(Applause).
>> Lisa?
>> Thanks. I'm going to
start with a little detail.
So when we got those
silicon graphics workstations
at the Media
Lab, which happened
just after I arrived,
they came with built-in fonts.
And they were awful.
But they also in
3D -- I think all
of them had thickness.
Like you were almost
sort of required to
use a Z
dimension. And I think,
you know, implying that
the software developers
from SGI were focused on
big extruded text. And one
of the things -- I
think it's an important
detail. Because the way those
fonts were built by
Dave and the team
was really not something
that was really designed
into the software that
landed on those workstations.
And it was very
much that condition that
they had absolutely no
thickness. And the
ability for them to
disappear on rotation. That was
really so much about
what that time was about.
But backing up, I just
want to -- I'm so
grateful that this event
is happening. Especially grateful
that this book
exists Thank you to Rob,
David and MIT Press for
making it happen And
to the designers. The book
is so beautiful. And it
will -- it's such a
perfect tribute to Muriel
Cooper's work. I was
really honored to be
asked to do the forward.
And I was given -- I'm
not surprised -- a really
impossible deadline to write
the forward for the
book. I thought, there's
no way I will meet
this deadline. And I did, much
to my surprise. And the
words, the anecdotes, the
experience, really just kind of
came out of me
And it was such
a pleasure. And really
meaningful right now. I'm
assuming no one has read
the forward yet. But in
many ways, it reads
as a kind of
instruction manual for how to
run a really successful
research lab. And sort
of serving my own current
agenda. Muriel -- part
of Muriel's brilliance, I think,
was in her collaborators. And
I also -- I
mean, you know, the VLW
would not have been the
place it was of
course without Ron
and Dave, Suguru. And
Louis Whitesman (phonetic)
is here. The group
of people that she
carefully curated was really
extraordinary. So I encourage
you to actually read
the whole book. The
essays are incredible.
Nicholas' afterwards is incredible
And again, if
you want a sense of what
it was like to be in
the VLW, please read it
Just a couple little anecdotes
to share. And this is
something that -- so
maybe we'll have a
conversation about this at
some point But Muriel
forbid technology conversations
at the VLW. Literally.
This is something
that I write about in
the forward. You could not
talk about technology in
front of her She
would tell you to
go to another room
(Chuckles).
>> It's true, right?
>> Yeah.
>> And there
was something incredibly important
about this. And absolutely
key to what
she was able to do in
separating these conversations
that were
really about experience, about
design, about communication,
about messages, from how
it was done. She
never let technology lead.
I mean,
we had those
conversations of course.
But they did not
lead. And I write about this
in the forward. I feel
like I did bring this
ethic, what I learned, to
Pentagram, which, of course, now --
when I joined Pentagram
I was kind of
the first digitally fluent
partner to join. My team
was very much -- I
mean, I built my practice
doing the digital interactive
work of my partners who
were doing these --
still doing these
amazing identity programs
for corporate institutional
clients. But what really
became strategic, of course, as
we knew was to
have that type of work
be done by all the
partners for their identity
programs. And again, you
should read the forward.
But when -- years
ago when people came
to Pentagram, when I started,
they asked for a
certain artifact of design.
A poster. An Annual Report
A book. And that
has completely changed. And
again, it's something that
-- so what
clients now ask for is
-- we have educated the
clients to ask for their
message to be communicated
to an audience It's
the work has become
really media agnostic. Anyways,
all of these things
I really took away
from my experience in the
VLW. I talk about --
there were a group of
students with diverse
set of backgrounds from
the computational side,
architecture, design. The work
-- Muriel had really guided
us. She didn't --
she taught in a very
unusual way. I didn't even
know that I was being
taught exactly. But I
was really being guided. And
in hindsight I look
back. And in some ways the
heaviest hand was really in
the choice of typefaces.
(Chuckles).
>> And there were
many weights. But there
was one typeface,
which was Helvetica. So
this diversity of work that
we produced had --
came together in that way.
And lastly, I had toe
write about what --
I wanted to write
and sort of conclude
the forward with
what I felt really
motivated her. I think she
was -- there were
contradictions in that.
I distinctly remember
this conversation with
either Ron or another
designer, graphic designer, who
was visiting. And
they were -- I
was just overhearing this
conversation with Muriel. And
they were talking about
the one word that would
be kind of devastating
to hear about
their work. Do
you remember this?
>> Oh, yeah.
>> And do you remember the word?
>> Oh, yeah. Nice.
>> Oh, okay
>> I had a different memory
of the word. >
> It didn't matter
what the word was as
long as you cried.
>> Okay. (Chuckles).
>> The
word I remember
was decorative.
>> Oh, yes.
>> Similar; similar
>> So on the
one hand, Muriel, you know,
wanted there to be meaning,
she wanted to communicate.
She wanted it to map to
the experience of the content.
She wanted
it to represent
the content.
She wanted her
work to represent
the content On
the other hand, another memory
I have is I was
on the reality engine,
flying her through a
financial visualization I had
done. She actually gave
me the Morningstar floppy
disk so I could use
that information. And I
remember I was kind of
driving the demo and she
was sitting back in
the chair. And she really
-- she asked me to
kind of pause. She really
wanted to occupy the
space of numbers. She
actually -- despite the
other comment -- this contradiction
is she wanted to feel it, she
wanted to be seduced
by the form. And I
think it was really those
two things of wanting the
meaning, you know, wanting
the content. And wanting
just the seduction
and the pleasure of
beautiful form. And flying,
as Richard said. She
wanted to fly. So -- and
lastly, when I tried to sum
this up in the forward, I
was writing a sentence
about what really motivated
her. There's an M
dash. I was trying to
put the words together. And
I concluded that what
motivated her
really was what
was possible.
>> Very good.
>> So thank
you. And great
to be here.
(Applause).
>> I think we're running
a little late so we'll
take just another couple
of minutes David,
I was going
to ask you, you said
outside, you said, boy,
I'm looking back. And gee,
I didn't really study with
Muriel for all that long.
It was only ten years.
(Chuckles).
> > And my recollection --
>> It felt so much longer.
>> But my recollection
is you changed quite a
lot over those ten years.
I thought you could say a
little bit about what you were like
when you started with Muriel and --
>> Yeah. I -- she
-- I mean, like many
people, she changed my life.
But I feel like,
wow, she really changed the
trajectory of my life.
When I started,
I hadn't written any
software per se.
At least not at
MIT as an undergraduate.
I had worked in
the dark room.
But that was all
just with chemistry.
And I didn't really
know anything about design I
had finished my undergrad.
I didn't have a job.
I didn't know quite what
I was going to do.
And I don't know if
it was she or I. But
we talked about like, what
should I do next? She
says, well, come do work
in the Visible Language
Workshop. And you know, thank
God that I did. So
I started out like that.
Bob Sabiston taught me
all he knew about software.
And I taught other
people And we all taught
each other. None of us --
a lot of people came
to the VLW not knowing
how to program. And none
of us started by
taking Computer Science course
in how to program.
We taught each
other. And that was going
to be enough. And yeah,
in those ten years,
everything changed so dramatically
in the way that I
had absorbed all of
this idea about stuff. And I
never felt like she taught me
-- like I was being
taught. I
kind of complained
about it sometimes
(Chuckles).
>> Where is the
textbook? Is there ever going
to be a textbook?
Are you even
working on the
textbook? No.
There was no chance there
was ever going to be
the textbook to come out.
Which, you know, a lot
of people at the lab,
they had a group.
And they solely developed
that book. That was
not going to happen.
But it was like this.
It was like this --
this is the Bob Sabiston
view of the
Visible Language Workshop. And
it was like tied t
ogether with duct tape
and there were a bunch
of speakers and smoke
coming out of things. And at
the end of it, I had
learned all of this stuff.
And I didn't even
quite realize how much
she was teaching me
>> Yeah. I have
two more really quick questions.
One is for you, Ron.
I was thinking at
the end of the day
-- these last two days
have been our
members Sponsor Days at
the Media Lab.
At the end of the
day yesterday after it was
hectic all day, our newest
faculty member, Danielle
Wood, who is a
remarkable young woman who
works at
NASA and also works
on community activism,
was walking around looking
at demos. And she
came to our group
and my students were
all around. She asked --
she's just starting at the
Media Lab. And
she said, what is it
that makes a group bond?
What is it
that makes a group
feel special? And I
immediately thought of all of
the groups I've ever seen
at the Media Lab.
There was something
about the feeling at
the Visible Language
Workshop that was just special.
And I was wondering, you
know, just in a
few words, can you
think how that worked? Why
that happened? Tell Danielle
>> Right. Because as you
saw, which chose superb people. And
there really was no roadmap.
There was a work
space. And some, you know,
general ideas of things.
And we all sort
of dived in. And got
to work. I mean,
I don't think
it was much more
complicated than that.
>> My last
quick question for
Lisa is,
you told me before
that you have a
daughter. She's 13 you said?
>> She'll be 10 on Monday.
>> She'll be
10. Who is
interested in design.
Interested in MIT. And I
just thought maybe you would tell
everyone what her name is.
>> Her name is Muriel.
>> Thanks.
(Applause).
[Music].
>> I'm Muriel's nephew,
Jonathan. And on behalf
of Muriel's family, many
of whom are here tonight,
a big thank you to the
Press and to the Media Lab
for hosting
and including us in
this great event.
Much of the talk
today has been about
Muriel's role as a
teacher and designer. But
before she was either, she
was the first born
child of immigrant Russian
and Polish parents living
in Brookline. It was
a typical middle class
family Jack, her father,
was a master electrician.
And her mother, Jenny, stayed
at home to take care
of the family. Muriel
or Candy as she was
called, was her nickname, was
followed by the birth
of my mother, Helene,
who is also known as
Honey. And lastly Charlotte,
who is here tonight,
who was known as
Chicky. Wonderful names.
(Chuckles).
>> Muriel had a pretty
normal childhood. The only hint
of what was to
become a brilliant
career might have been
a passion for doodling
and her being at
the time what was called
a tomboy but today
would simply be
described as being fearless,
strong willed and
independent. When it was time for college, Muriel attend
Ohio State with the goal of getting her BFA.
But when Jack and Jenny would visit her on
Parents Day Weekend, they
were shocked to discover
that the dorm that
Muriel was staying in
was filled with girls
of questionable character.
(Chuckles).
>> Who were smoking, leaving
clothes all over the floor
and God knows what else.
In their opinion Ohio
State was far too racy a
place for their little girl.
So Muriel was allowed
to finish the year and
then was brought back
to Boston where
she enrolled at the
Massachusetts College of Art
to pursue a career
in art education. When I
applied to art schools
and was obsessing
about which art school
I should attend,
Muriel calmly told me to
relax. The school is unimportant.
It's who you go
to school with. I can
see why she felt that
way. Muriel's classmates at
Mass Art included a
who's who of future
designers and artists, including
Tom Wong and Jackie
Casey, both of whom could
often be found sitting
around the Cooper dining
room table, pulling a
charrette for the next
morning's class. They
three became life-long friends.
Jack and Jenny
often worried about Muriel
Why wasn't she married?
Why didn't she
conform like her siblings?
Why did she dress the
way she dressed? They
could only see that Muriel
didn't fit the mold that
her younger sisters did
and they didn't see her
brilliance. Muriel was my aunt.
But she was much
more than that to me.
She was my mentor, my
idol, and my best friend.
She was cool. She was
loud. She could be brash. And
she was a big part
of why I became a
designer. Well, to be honest,
in large part, it was
because of her basement.
Every year would start
with a call. Muriel
asking if I would like
to come by some weekend
and help clean up her
basement. And every year
I leapt at the chance.
I would spend hours
upon hours in that
basement with Muriel asking
her questions about
where she had gotten
this or that object. Where
she thought a particular
item should go. And
she would patiently show
me how to plan,
categorize and organize. Looking
back, I guess it
was the equivalent to
Mr. Miyagi's wash on/wax
off method of karate
training, except for a
designer. To me, that
basement was a playground.
A library. A time
capsule. And a toy store
all rolled into one. And
I can remember the
contents of each box
and shelf like it was
yesterday. Walking down the
steep basement stairs, I
spy a rusty erector set,
barely contained by it's
decaying box. It was
a gift from Muriel's parents
to keep her occupied
while she was recovering
from appendicitis when she
was 10 years old.
And Charlotte recently told
me when Muriel first asked
for an erector set,
her mother replied, what on
earth would a girl do
with an erector set?
And great things apparently
A large wok framed
by a bamboo steaming
basket sits on a
shelf, part of a collection
of kitchen gadgets, a
byproduct of Muriel's
adventures in Chinese cooking.
My brother, David,
lived at Muriel's house
while he attended BU in
the '60s and remembers
going with Muriel to
Chinatown where she would spend
half of her time
purchasing exotic ingredients
with barely pronounceable
names and the
other half chatting with
the store owners. Muriel
loved exploring world
cuisines long before it
became commonplace. And one
section of the
basement is filled with
clothes. A few from
India with fantastic colors
and patterns. Some from
Japan. Rich in their
simplicity and detail. And
many, many, many from
Filene's Basement. I think it
was Elise Brink, a
good friend of Muriel's, who
told the story of how she
joined in on one of
Muriel's famous trips to
Filene's. Muriel went up to
the returns desk and
placed a very large pile
of clothes on the counter.
And the woman at the
counter slowly looked through
the pile and shook
her head and
explained, they couldn't
explain the return. The
clothes had been
purchased over a year ago.
It was too late to
return them. And without
missing a beat, Muriel
calmly explained the reason
she hadn't returned
them sooner was because
she had been locked
away in a mental
institution for the past
year and she had
just been released. They
nervously
accepted her
return.
(Chuckles).
>> There are
watches, some analogue and some
digital. Most are broken,
which might have been
a factor in her
seeming inability to arrive anywhere
on time. Large
piles of parking tickets
held together by rubber bands.
A souvenir of
her apparent refusal to
ever pay for parking
. Causing the Cambridge
police to show up
at her office at MIT
and threaten to cuff
and arrest her on the
spot in order to get her
to pay them.
And there are family
photographs, magazines and
clippings. One clipping
features a photograph
of Muriel standing
in an all-white
room and the headline
states: Designer boldly
paints home
interior white.
(Chuckles).
>> The article
goes onto describe
how Muriel Cooper
of Brookline
in a radical move
breaking with tradition has
decided to paint the
interior of her house completely
white. I know, crazy.
On the floor sits
an unopened pack of cigarettes.
As I bend down
to pick them up, I
get a clear image of
Muriel's habit of approaching a
random smoker. A total
stranger. Asking if she
might smell their
cigarette. She would hold
it in her hands
delicately like a wine
connoisseur might hold the
cork of a fine
vintage wine. Deeply inhaling
from the flowing tip. A
look of ecstasy spreading over
her face. I've quit
smoking, she would
explain. But God, I
miss the smell
(Chuckles).
>> There's a box of
calculators on the floor. A
souvenir of a calculus
class. One of
many that Muriel
audited at MIT.
I remember how
frustrated she would get
doing problem sets.
Often cursing and
swearing outloud. And how
at the time
I wondered why
anyone would take a
math class unless
they absolutely had to. There
are cameras, lots and lots
of cameras. 35 millimeter,
4 by 4 And
larger slide projectors, movie
cameras. 16 millimeter,
8 millimeter. Super
8. And of course
Polaroid cameras A
medium that she loved. Right
next to them is what
can only be described
as a shrine
to all things Sony.
Recorders, microphones, headphones,
Walkman, Betamax cameras
and players, laser
disks, editing equipment.
I realize that I'm
looking at the complete history
of Sony Corporation up
to 1994 as curated by
Muriel Cooper. There are toys
on a shelf. Mostly
robots from Japan. Her
latest fascination. And they
trigger a memory of
the elaborate Viking ship Muriel
gave me when I was
5 or so, complete
with articulated oars that
would row in sync as
it slowly moved sails
billowing across the floor. It
was and continues to be
the best present I
ever got. But most of
the basement is taken up
by books. And I take
frequent breaks having picked up
a book to place it
on a shelf only to
stop, sit on the
floor, and leaf through its
pages. Bauhaus, "Learning from
Las Vegas", filed under
architecture, the whole earth
catalog, books by
Paul Rand Josef
Albers, Push Pin magazine,
upper case/lower case
comic books. Not even
reading. Just absorbing the
pacing, the structure,
the color, the visual
impact that each page
contained. And I was
mesmerized by the cover
designs, the fonts and the
images. And at the
time I didn't even realize
her connection to these books
that I was falling
in love with. Every item
in that basement was precious
to Muriel. If I
asked why I couldn't throw
out a calculator, a Betamax
player, or a gear
bag, all of them
long since broken or obsolete,
Muriel would comment on
how the interface, packaging
or design was cute.
And cute was the
highest form of flattery
that Muriel could bestow on
an object or idea.
We spent many weekends
together at the flea
market in Squantum,
coming upon a vendor
selling an interesting old
sees or piece of
equipment. Muriel would
immediately start a
conversation with the
seller. She was not only
curious about the story behind
an object, but the
story of the owner, as
well. And after ten minutes
or so of chatting, she
would stop, pause, look
out over her reading
glasses and remark, "Cute."
And the poor vendor
would look so confused Was
cute meant as a
putdown? Should they
be offended or
complicated? They didn't
understand that coming
from Muriel cute was
the highest of
compliments. I was with
Muriel when she died
in Mass General Hospital
in May of 1994. And I
can honestly say, like many of
you, not a day has
gone by that I haven't
thought about her. I'm not
a religious man. But I've
always liked the song Rock
and Roll Heaven, which is
goes, if there's a
Rock and Roll Heaven, well,
you know they've got a
hell of a band. So
who knows? Maybe there's
a graphic design heaven.
And Jackie, Tom
and Muriel are in
a white cloud-filled room
sitting around the table,
laughing and drinking wine.
They are solving design
problems we can't
possibly imagine. It's
just another day of
a perfect never-ending
charrette. Then suddenly at
this very moment, Muriel
pauses, gets that
twinkle in her eye,
peers out over her reading
glasses, and comments on
how cute our
celebration here today has
been. Thank you.
(Applause).
>> Two more short speakers. And I
would like to thank you for coming.
You will not see me again.
And Joi Ito is our next
speaker And Amy Brand, who is
the head of the MIT Press
is our last speaker.
If a parent can give their
child to a foster home
or to somebody else and
be really happy with where
that child is placed,
I, in some sense, gave
my child to Joi Ito
who has been the director
of the Media Lab
for he reminded me
yesterday almost six years.
I think of it
as yesterday. And when Joi joined,
it was the best thing
that happened to this place. So
Joi, you didn't know Muriel. But
you're cut from the same cloth
(Applause)
>> Thank you, everybody.
And I really appreciate
everybody coming together
to celebrate Muriel
And it's interesting. It's
not the happiest thing.
But we have
recently lost Seymour and Marvin
and this feels to me
like a kind
of culmination of this
sort of historical retrospective
of the founding
faculty of the Media
Lab. And I think it's,
for me, in addition
to hearing about all of
their work through students
and faculty, through
Nicholas, meeting all
of the people
who were connected to
them and listening to
the conversations really
helps me understand where a
lot of this stuff comes
from And this kind
of very strong creativity,
disobedience, and this sort
of fearlessness that
sort of embodies the
Media Lab. And I've known
Nicholas for a long
time. But as I start
to see these other people
who are involved, I'm
starting to understand more
and more about the DNA.
And it's I think
quite a testament to the
founding faculty at the Media
Lab that 31 years
now later, you can still feel
the DNA. And I think that
this -- the fact that
we're still on a trajectory
that was set by the
original founders and set so
strongly is a testament
to both their vision and
their character. So today
has been really wonderful
in sort of understanding
that. I'm peculiarly
sort of overlapping with Muriel
on that I'm also on
the Board of the MIT
Press. I'm an author there
and also the director of
the Media Lab. And I
think Muriel played a
very important role in bringing
the Press and the
Media Lab together. And
we're also continuing that. And
I think there's a
demonstration in the auditorium.
But we've launched a
journal called the
Journal of Design and Science.
So a lot of art
-- Neri has a wonderful
CREB cycle that I think
I got from John Maeda, who
got it from Rich Gold.
But there's sort of
four quadrants where you have
art and science and
design and engineering And
we've done a lot of
art and engineering at
the Media Lab but the
sort of design and science
axis hadn't been fully
explored in my view so
we created a journal and
the idea was that we
brought a lot of hard
scientists into the Media Lab.
And you realize when
you meet hard scientists is
that they tend to be
very focused and not
very aware of the
context about the sensibilities
that you need when you
think about things. And
not really responsible necessarily
for the overall
possibility of the stuff
that they are interacting with.
And conversely, a lot
of the designers we have
talked to, or I've talked
to especially when we
look at MIT, we have
hundreds of classes that have
the word design. But
sort of design --
Muriel has sort of morphed
into systems design and
design of business practices.
And design of all kinds
of things. And it's
become very engineery. And
there are even sort of
moves to sort of
remove the aesthetic side
of design. And one of
the things that I've
noticed as we look
at complex self-adaptive systems
like the climate,
like the human body,
that what's missing is the
kind of sensibility. It's
you're doing things without
this approach of trying
to make the thing
work in a wonderful way.
And that, in fact, the
future of design is
probably going back to a
sensibilityand aesthetics,
a kind of vision that
I think goes back to where we were
starting. So to me, bringing design
and science together, bringing
a new science into
design, bringing design
into science is really
important. I think that's very
much Media Lab, very
much MIT, very much
Muriel. So that's the journal
that we launched. And
we're launching it also
on a platform called
PubPub. Which was
developed at the Media
Lab. And it's a weird
platform that allows people
to make comments. It
allows you to version, track
the versions. It's very
much a sort of living
document of -- and creates sort
of a new way of
thinking about peer review
so it's much more
participatory. So we would
love you to take a look
and tell us what you think.
And I think -- let's see
what else I'm supposed to
talk about. Yeah, and I
think the main thing is
that, you know, as we
sort of embark on this
next journey, thinking about
how the work that Muriel
has done and the work
that Amy Brand, who
you'll meet, who is the
new director of MIT Press,
how we can move this
forward is one of the
core missions of the Media
Lab. So I really
appreciate your past support
and your future support. And
with that -- oh,
one last thing I'm supposed to
say is that there's going to
be in that room --
in the Alex Dreyfoos
Auditorium there will be a
video of Muriel's TED5
talk from 1994. So please
take a look at that
during the reception. So
with that, I would like
to ask Amy Brand, the
director of MIT Press to
come up. Thank you.
(Applause).
>> I just think
this has been a wonderful
occasion and thank you,
Joi, to mark this
enduring partnership between
the Press and the Media Lab.
The way that Joi
was talking about the
Media Lab and the sort
of quadrant or
nexus of design and
science and art and technology
is very much
the DNA of the
MIT Press, as well.
And I think a lot
of that does go back
to Muriel. So just 30
seconds for me. Lots of
thank yous. I wish to
thank all of our amazing
speakers and panelists and
in particular, I really
want to thank Nicholas
for co-hosting this event.
I know that it's really,
really heartfelt for you,
Nicholas. And I appreciate
that, given your deep
friendship. And I only
wish I had known
Muriel, too. One person that
we haven't mentioned this
evening but really needs
to be thanked is Roger
Conover, who is sitting
right over there. Roger
is celebrating 40 years as
an art and architecture
editor at the MIT
Press. And he's created
this incredible legacy around
publishing and art and
architecture and design So
please talk to him.
(Applause).
>> Now, you might
have thought listening to
John Maeda that you're actually
going to have to
buy the book. But in
fact, due to a generous
gift from the School
of Architecture and planning
and Hashim Sarkis,
everybody who was invited to
this event will leave with
a copy of the book.
So . . . I would
like to thank -- yes. That's
up there. So thank you, Hashim.
(Applause).
>> But please, if you
have more people you want
to buy books for,
they are there for purchase,
as well. And Pentagram, we're
just in awe of you.
And in particular, again, I
would like to thank Aron
Fay and Daisy Lee,
who provided those
really gorgeous animations.
We're definitely
going to try to make use
of them at the MIT presence
the one at the end.
Many people at the
Press and the Lab were
involved in making this
event possible. I can't try
to list all of them.
But there really are three heroes
of the evening. They
are Ellen Hoffman and Kate
Shanaghan and Kate Strauss,
a really incredible
and tireless event
planning trio.
They have impeccable
taste. They have
great humor. And
they made me involved in
planning this event a real
joy and privilege. So
thank you to all of them.
(Applause)
>> And thanks to all
of you for coming. And
please go and enjoy the reception.
Thank you.
(Applause)
[Music]